der Nico lange ist bei uns in der
Sendung militär-experte und Russland
Kenner Herr lange bevor wir über die
Hilfen noch mal sprechen erst noch mal
zur Lage an der Grenze zwischen Polen
und Weißrussland da schreiben jetzt auch
viele Userinnen und User im Hinblick
darauf zum Beispiel Michael Rossmann
könnte es sein dass der Putsch eine
doppeltaktik ist und in Wirklichkeit die
Wagner sollten dann nun ihre Kräfte in
Bella Rust sammeln und von dort Kiew
angreifen und noch eine Frage dazu haben
die Ukraine genug Kräfte für einen zwei
Fronten Krieg
also die Antwort auf beide Fragen ist
ich sehe überhaupt keine Gefahr dass
jetzt Wagner Kräfte von Belarus aus Kiew
angreifen könnten
ich glaube auch überhaupt gar nicht dass
dieser Putschversuch irgendwie gespielt
war oder dass das ein Plan war um die
nach Belarus zu kriegen also die hätten
ja nach Belarus gehen können wo ist das
Problem ob die jemals in Belarus
ankommen halt ist sogar für fraglich
weil das sind ja individuelle Angebote
die Putin gemacht hat an die
wagnerkämpfer sie könnten sich
entscheiden ob sie entweder nach Belarus
gehen oder nach Hause oder ob sie in die
russischen Streitkräfte integriert
werden können ähm da weiß man ja gar
nicht wie sich die einzelnen Personen
entscheiden das ist jedenfalls nicht so
dass die gesamte wagnergruppe genommen
wird und nach Bäder rausgebracht wird
zumal völlig unklar ist was die da
überhaupt tun sollen für eine Angriff
auf Kiew da bräuchte man eine riesige
Anzahl von Kräften die Ukraine haben
damit mittlerweile gestaffelte
Verteidigungsstellung das kann man also
mit ein paar tausend WAG Kämpfern nicht
bewerkstelligen und auch was einen
Angriff auf nato-gebiet von Belarus
anbetrifft würde ich mir da nicht die
größten Sorgen machen in Bezug auf die
wagnergruppe das ganze ist vor allen
Dingen eine schlechte Botschaft für
Belarus also Lukaschenko versucht zwar
zu sagen dass man die zeitweise dort
aufnimmt aber wenn er die dort erstmal
hätte würde er sie nicht mehr los und
die würden natürlich auch auf ihn ein
bisschen aufpassen und er hat schon mit
der Lagerung von russischen Atomwaffen
sehr stark an Souveränität eingebüßt mit
den wagnerkräften würde er das noch mehr
tun und es ist auch für alle die eine
Veränderung von Belarus wollen natürlich
keine gute Botschaft wenn man jetzt
diese seltener da hat die uns
Zweifelsfall dann für die russischen
Interessen und für Putin eher einstehen
würden als sich da irgendwie positiv
einzubringen in Belarus also die
schlechten Nachrichten hat vor allen
Dingen wieder raus
Herr Lange sie waren lange für die
Adenauer Stiftung in der Ukraine unter
anderem sie waren Staatssekretär im
Bundesverteidigungsministerium sind
jetzt für die Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz auch tätig sie
haben auch in St Petersburg waren sie
tätig also sie haben sehr sehr guten
Einblick in die Situation und auch in
die Bedürfnisse der Ukrainer wenn wir
darauf blicken dass in Brüssel jetzt
gerade wieder darüber gesprochen wird
was die Ukraine braucht was ist das aus
ihrer Sicht daran Hass gerade gesagt aus
der Ukraine kommt der Wunsch nach mehr
Luftabwehr und Luftunterstützung und
hier fragen viele User ist es jetzt
nicht an der Zeit die F16 zu liefern
das ist schon lange an der Zeit die ab
16 zu liefern und das ist unverständlich
warum wir für alles immer so lange
brauchen ist gut dass wir schützen und
Kampfpanzer liefern haben wir aber viel
zu spät entschieden ist gut dass die F16
kommen werden aber auch das ist viel zu
spät entschieden worden jetzt dauert es
noch eine Weile um die logistische Kette
aufzubauen und die Piloten werden ja
schon seit einiger Zeit ausgebildet
deswegen bin ich zuversichtlich das ist
gar nicht mehr so lange dauern wird
einige Monate noch bis wir die
Unterstützung mit F16 sehen werden bei
der EU ist natürlich wichtig dass die EU
mit Makro finanziellen Hilfen also mit
Geld das letztlich den ukrainischen
Staatshaushalt stützt dafür sorgt dass
es der Grundlagen gibt es leben sie sind
ja viele Ukrainerinnen Ukraine
zurückgekehrt und die müssen ja
irgendwie leben können es muss auch
irgendwie eine wirtschaftliche Aktivität
geben Schulen müssen funktionieren
Infrastrukturen müssen funktionieren und
da spielt die EU eine ganz wichtige
Rolle und hat ja glücklicherweise gerade
entschieden dass in den nächsten vier
Jahren mit 50 Milliarden Euro die
Ukraine unterstützt werden soll das ganz
wichtig und die EU hat eine neue Rolle
eingenommen nämlich mit der sogenannten
friedensfazilität also einem
finanziellen Instrument waffenausrüstung
und Munition zu kaufen und das auch so
stark zu tun dass sogar die
Produktionskapazitäten erhöht werden
können vor allen Dingen bei Munition und
das halte ich für eine gute Entwicklung
weil wir diesen langen Krieg und die
Unterstützung der Ukraine in diesem
langen Krieg nur entscheiden können in
einem Sinne der Abwehr des russischen
Angriffes wenn jetzt auch genügend
produziert wird dass man in die Ukraine
ständig nachliefern kann dass die
Ukraine Ersatzteile bekommt und Munition
wenn die EU das noch ein bisschen
schneller machen würde wäre das noch
besser
eine letzte Frage aus der Community an
sie verlange Detlef Hammer fragt Herr
Lange wie wahrscheinlich ist ein
schnelles Ende des Krieges
ein schnelles Ende des Krieges wird
wahrscheinlich ja in zwei Fällen ich
glaube ein Russland ohne Putin vor dem
man keine Angst haben sollte und wir
haben am Wochenende glaube ich ein
Vorgeschmack darauf gekriegt wie schnell
das eigentlich gehen könnte dass ich da
was verändert ein Russland ohne Putin
gebe jemanden neuen die Chance diesen
Krieg schnell zu beenden die Truppen
zurückzuziehen und etwas anderes
anzufangen also wir sollten da keine
Angst haben dass da irgendwas
schlimmeres passiert ich glaube
schlimmer als Putin kann es nicht werden
und die zweite Möglichkeit ist wenn die
Ukraine genügend Ausstattungen
Ausrüstung bekommt wenn wir nicht so
zögerlich und so schrittweise liefern
sondern uns mal entschlossen dahinter
klemmen und alles liefern was notwendig
ist dann wäre die Ukraine in der Lage
die Front zu durchbrechen und die
russischen Truppen letztlich zu
vertreiben und das ist ja letztlich auch
der Weg der zu einem nachhaltigen
Frieden führen könnte in beiden Fällen
gibt es Frieden nur wenn die russischen
Truppen das Gebiet der Ukraine wieder
verlassen dass aus meiner Sicht das was
wir unbedingt brauchen